Hello, and welcome to Lesson 4. In Lesson 4, you will be working with numbers
and with strings. You already know that you use integers for whole numbers and
the type called double for numbers that can have fractional parts. So far, that
seems pretty easy, but there's some things that you need to know so that you
stay out of trouble. Let me give you an example. Have a look at this statement
over here. We initialize the variable one million with well, one million. We
multiply one million by itself, that gives us one trillion, which is a number
with a lot of zeroes. And we put this into mystery, now you can already tell
that something is going to go wrong. Otherwise, I wouldn't have name this
variable a mystery. So go ahead, fire up BlueJ and type these statements into
the code pad. Or if you prefer, use the Udacity ID. When you're done, tell me
what you got for mystery.